il faut noter qu'il y avait un ministre
français aujourd'hui aux états unis
nicolas sarkozy avait fait le
déplacement pour rassurer les américains
de l'amitié de la france et faire
entendre aussi sa différence sur ses
relations franco-américaines si
passionnel reportage michaël darmon
grégory bros ils ne participent à la
cérémonie aux côtés de george bush
mais il a tenu à faire partie de
l'événement dans une caserne sur la 8e
avenue nicolas sarkozy des corps des
pompiers new yorkais et s'adresse à un
jeune orphelin du 11 septembre
je voudrais est entouré de jeunes qui a
exactement l'âge de mon fils mais qui a
une différence avec mon fils c'est qu'il
a perdu son père qui était pompier à new
york sur son agenda c'est le dernier
déplacement aux usa avant le début de la
campagne présidentielle ce qui n'échappe
pas aux quelques badauds qui le
reconnaissent je sais qu'il veut être
premier ministre ou président je crois
qu'il va se présenter
mais bon peut-être un échange de bons
procédés de s'échanger des médailles ne
voit pas vraiment la donne pour nicolas
sarkozy c'est l'occasion de lancer un
message est oui j'aime les américains gm
leur énergie j'aime le fait que tout
soit possible j'aime la fluidité de la
société africaine
qu'est-ce qu'on veut que je suis un
admirateur de la société russe la liste
est notre modèle en venant le 11
septembre à new york nicolas sarkozy
choisit un jour consensuel mais le
presque candidat à l'élection
présidentielle persiste et signe il
réaffirme ses liens avec la société
américaine est à noter club